les rues de la petite communauté crie de
masques watch et au sud d'edmonton avait
besoin d'une nouvelle couche d'asphalté
depuis longtemps des visites du pape par
finalement poussé du gouvernement de
l'alberta a débloqué il fonds
nécessaires mais ici lieu du premier
arrêt du pape au pays se contentera de
réparer n'auriez de cosmétiques
ou si johnson lui montre le terrain se
trouvait jadis le pensionnat romane skin
son père rien subi de nombreux abus et
visiter des excuses sur place du pape ne
suffiront pas à faire disparaître sa
colère
[Musique]
la mascotte juste les leaders de la
communauté apprécié le fait que le pape
s'arrête chez eux pour reconnaître les
torts de l'église même si cette visite
qui ravive de nombreux traumatismes ne
fait pas l'unanimité est encore
[Musique]
l'expérience du sras pas positif pour
tout le monde souligne lucie johnson
lieux de pèlerinage catholique pour les
métiers c'est les premières nations de
l'ouest le lac sainte anne occupé des
jeunes place importante dans la
spiritualité autochtone avant l'arrivée
du christianisme que le pape françois
viennent y prier avec les autochtones
envoie un bon message prend le chef
local
répétées des excuses pour les
pensionnats viendra confirmer une fois
pour toutes les terribles souffrances
content ignorer ou remise en question
tony à l'excès soirée mais que le pape
presse au lac sainte anne plus longtemps
mais il souhaite surtout que l'humilité
dont il fait preuve durant son séjour au
canada laissera sa marque sur l'ensemble
de l'église catholique potter tu te tais
n'était
ce taux est
[Musique]
de passage en alberta le pape rossi a
narré dans cette église du centre-ville
d'edmonton a lourdement endommagé par un
incendie il ya deux cette église dédiée
aux premières nations au métier sivos
inuits coup ses portes juste à temps
pour la visite papale
oui l'aîné frimin this is an encore plus
chez lui alors que la reconstruction
achève chaque et les marges pictural
porte une signification autochtone
particulière une façon de dire que
malgré le traumatisme des pensionnats
les autochtones du canada ont leur place
au sein d'églises catholiques
fini qui comprend que pour plusieurs la
douleur et la colère persiste mais il
préfère voir dans cette visite une
occasion à saisir leur réconciliation
est vraiment possible si l'église est
sincère dans sa démarche tous les
autochtones ne sont pas prêts à se
réconcilier avec elle reconnaît
l'archevêque dès maintenant il faut
rencontrer la personne où la personne se
trouve le respecter et de ce moment-là
trouver des manières d'avancer penseront
recevoir la visite du chef de l'église
demeure un événement joyeux pour les
katas les canadiens croit le
coordonnateur général de la visite
papale mais il assure que la raison de
ce séjour du pape canada ne sera pas
éclipser le cannabis était vraiment
sombre il y a
le sentiment à penser à la travers tout
ça
pasqua ciesla visite du père françois ne
durera quelques heures
les excuses du pape marqueront une
avancée vers la réconciliation
mais il faudra du temps pour en mesurer
l'impact construire le chemin de la
guérison ne se fera pas en quelques
jours ici mathieu gaye et radio canada